hello my name is Mario and I'm going to
be doing a maybe a non-conventional
crash course for you in L I work at
trouble port locomote and travel port is
one of the three major GDS is in the
world
hands up have you ever taken a flight
before anywhere one in three chance we
sold you that flight locomote what we do
is we do corporate travel and so those
of you that work at a big corporate
awesome come and talk to me later we
have a great product for you oh yeah we
do corporate travel management and we've
been acquired by trout port so as you
can probably tell by the accent I am NOT
English British I come from Australia
and our company was started in Melbourne
but with the acquisition I now live and
work in London you can find me on github
my handle is super Mario that is my
actual real handle so the goals for what
I'm going to do tonight I was originally
thinking of doing on the same format
what we do at the Ella Munden meetups
which is to actually do a code night you
pull out your laptops you actually work
on stuff people get in different groups
either you're going from scratch and I'm
doing a from scratch tutorial or you're
working on projects or you might be
advanced in helping with open source
stuff but I thought given that I've got
a room of presumably JavaScript and
react experienced developers the more
that I thought about it the the more I
thought about my own journey into
discovering kind of element functional
programming and the things that
prevented me from understanding the
value of those things to myself and what
they would give me in my kind of
day-to-day work and I thought it might
be more valuable if I gave you a swathe
of those kind of things because I found
those really hard to find online and
then you control through lots of blog
posts and things and try and scrape
things together but until you've really
kind of tasted element functional
programming for yourself it's really
hard to understand some of those
concepts so I wanted to maybe instead
give you a little bit of a teaser of
those things that you might not find so
easily and then give you the resources
of which there are plenty of for you to
just learn like LM syntax and stuff so
I'm gonna try and cover things that
might not be obvious I'm still going to
go through a little bit of elm so you
got a bit of grounding but I'm gonna
talk about some awesome things that
that exists in the own community that
may not be obvious straight away I'll
talk about some pitfalls and then I'll
give you some references for more stuff
cool so this is an ell map that you're
currently looking at some of you're
still joining so let's just start real
easy
how are you feeling no one's feeling
good hopefully awesome no one's feeling
bad that's great
JavaScript experience zero starting
confident or pro pro meaning you work in
JavaScript professionally okay so we've
got some people that are 0 some people
are starting this is gonna be awesome
for you for the rest of you you've got
prior knowledge that's gonna hold you
back I'm just kidding me Elm experience
has how is your Elm experience been in
terms of exposure or reading or anything
awesome we have some elm developers here
most of you 0 ok great so I'm hopefully
for those of you that are 0 this will be
informative and useful and help you
understand
one is elm something that you're
interested in investing your time in
and secondly what it might give you
generally okay cool
so normally what happens sorry normally
what happens with this is I go through a
set of live slides and you've got on
your devices a set of reactions so you
can give me like you're okay or you're
confused thumbs up thumbs down thinking
face falling asleep or bookmarks and
then at the end of the talk you can put
your email address in and get all that
stuff back sounds really awesome just
I'm not going to give it to you because
I didn't get to prepare the slide in
this software so we're not gonna use
this I'm gonna step out of it but this
is more just to give you an idea that
this is an app that I've used in past
talks um if you look at the Elm Europe
conference you can see me doing it live
on stage engaging the whole audience and
it's something that I've tried for a
number of years to build in lots of
other things and I always kind of go to
the point where I just couldn't keep
pushing further the complexity and
whatever language I worked and really
really held me back and I think this is
probably my best testament for myself
personally of
what Elm can give you as a developer
because the first time I've actually
been able to succeed with a project of
this kind of scale so anyway let's let's
run through the president you can come
talk to me afterwards if you want to
know more about the Elm software so I'm
gonna avoid these things today because I
think that there's better resources and
me speaking to you for finding that
stuff I'm so learning detailed syntax on
F P concepts as a whole and looking at
comprehensive code examples it's
probably better off in your own time and
at your own pace so I'm going to avoid
that kind of stuff but I will give you
things that you can look at afterwards
for diving into methods all those things
so what I am going to go through is I'm
gonna give you a high-level of what is
Elm I'm gonna try and disambiguate some
stuff that in my opinion I feel you
might run into if you try and learn it
yourself we'll run through some code but
at a very basic level and I'm gonna run
through the Elm architecture which i
think is probably one of the big
tripping points that people run into you
know this question of is L on the
library is it a language and trying to
figure out what it actually does and how
you do things I'm going to try to talk
through some some awesome things at
least as far as I find them roughly talk
about how do I use Elm at work which may
be a interest point to some of you and
I'll give you so you're some Cavett's
that I found for myself personally
awesome okay what is L so by its own
admission this is on the top of the elm
site Elm is a delightful language for
reliable web apps you generate
JavaScript with great performance and no
runtime exceptions that's almost
guaranteed so in more detail it's a
functional language it's statically
typed but it has type inference so if
you don't want to write types you can
not and elm will still figure out the
types of you up until a point all data
is immutable so there is no such thing
as immutable value or reference or
object in Elm
everything's immutable by default that's
part of the language
you can't opt out of that um all
functions are pure which means that
every piece of code that you ever look
at an elm the answer to the question of
what does this code do the answer is
nothing
it takes inputs and it returns a value
but it won't make any effect it won't
change anything in the outside world it
won't ask the outside world of anything
it will literally do nothing so every
line of code in any LM codebase you ever
look at has these two guarantees null
undefined in exceptions don't exist
they're not part of the platform they're
not part of the language you can't type
null and have it compile and nothing
within your elm code can throw an
exception or give you back a null so
those kind of things are removed from
the language so the these are all rather
intentional choices and they have some
really really interesting implications
when you when you don't have these kind
of things and you're all rather when you
have these kind of guarantees in your
language it actually comes out to be a
very very interesting subset of of the
kind of programming that you maybe
experienced and already so to answer the
question of exactly elm library this
kind of gets confusing when you start
looking at i'm stuff online if you're
familiar with i mean how many of you
using this kind of stack or somethin
loosely related to this yeah cool so you
know you get really excited you want to
start with javascript like right how do
you install packages so you can't you
gotta get npm right okay now have npm
like how do i bundle stuff together like
you can't you got to get word pack cool
and then you know react at the moment
you're all here because this is
reactivate but this is you know a more
recent paradigm before they used to be
many other choices and spine and
backbone and you know more modern lee I
guess angular as a competitor but
there's a lot of different options there
so you have to pick one maybe a pic
react then eventually you get to a point
where you've got too much local state
and your components are trying to send
stuff everywhere you know I have a solve
this problem then you go out Redux so
you learn Redux you bring that in now
you've got this problem where you know
you add a new action in redux and now
you don't know all the parts in your
code that need to be updated so maybe
you get something like typescript to
flow to bring some level of kind of
checking to figure out our I've added
stuff here and now my code breaks over
here so you kind of bring that into the
language then you get to the point where
like oh you know mutable references are
really killing us for passing objects
and accidentally setting methods on them
and losing control of our states you go
well maybe we need to bring
immutable jeaious into a stack so what's
the experience like when you start Elm
well you go well how do I get packages
that's built into Elm
yeah cool so how do I get all my files
compiled into a single version that's
built into Elm you go okay so how do I
actually architect my code how do I do
the view layer and all that kind of
stuff well that's actually building to
Elm so you go cool so how do I manage my
state when it gets really big that's
built into Elm
what about type checking and flow that's
built into elm and immutability as I
mentioned it's also built into L so the
analogy I've been trying to use recently
for this as people say well it can't be
a language it has too many features it'd
probably be I'm assuming similar to
originally when memory management was
all manual and your a/c developer and
something like JavaScript came along no
like we have automatic memory memory
management now you like so that's a
library you're like no no it's a
language feature like I can't be a
language feature like that's to feature
for so this is kind of the same in that
same sense so when we say that Ellen has
these things built in it's not built in
as a library that you use it is actually
the language so there's only one
architecture in Elm it's called the Elm
architecture there's only one way to
structure on that initial set of code
and that's all baked in all the
libraries that you build in or for
various other bits and bobs around is
that making sense getting some done
slowly now it's not all in isolation
there is kind of like a lot of cross
flow and lots of lots of the stuff
that's in that react stack if you're
ready familiar with it what's the stuff
in Elmwood just seem really really
natural so this is just a quote from the
down Abramov author of redux who has
quoted as pulling certain ideas back
from Elm so if you use redux they're
actually using a subset of the same kind
of function that operates in Elm so that
kind of stuff will come natural to do
the the difference I feel though is that
here you've got a lot of disparate
components with lots of different
authors different styles and different
integration points
whereas in elm the whole ecosystem is
built around the premise that the core
language has these functions so there's
a huge amount of effort put into them
working together really really really
really nicely so a lot of the pain
points that you may see on the left hand
side when you kind of come over to the
Elm side and my experience has been
those pain points are either way reduced
or just non-existent I'm in that kind of
environment so let me dive a little bit
deeper into that side note let's just
take a slight detour I'll come back
there's a personal bugbear of mine and
it maybe won't be the same for all of
you but it really impacted my ability to
learn functional because when I came up
against these two things I was really
defensive of my existing experience and
a bit insulted that that could possibly
be something that I didn't already know
in programming so for me it was really
humbling having to probably battle
through a year worth of self learning
before I got kind of passed these
concepts and I think that they're
needlessly complicated I'm especially
has anyone here tried to learn Haskell
or a dress or any other kind of
functional languages well I'm hoping
your experience is better than mine but
you know like space burritos and
homomorphisms over functor monads and
it's kind of like the mathematics in the
language and the kind of tone of that
community is really really really
difficult to approach so I just wanted
to kind of debunk two things that
hopefully will help you separate hype
from understanding a little bit more so
two things I'm breaking one functional
so what do mean what do we mean when we
say breakable yes I know it was a bit of
a clique beatty title saying building on
break cool software I'm gonna give you
two statements first statement being is
the sky is green most of you probably
think that's wrong but like what if
we're writing a computer game you know
and maybe the sky is green or what if
we're in the northern hemisphere and
it's nighttime so this guy's green for
those reasons might be wrong might be
not like this is this is about semantics
right this is what our job as
programmers is to take models of the
real world and underst
their semantics and then emulate them in
code and we can get that wrong and
probably unlikely for quite some time
that anything's gonna automatically
replace that right because that's the
thinking and the logic that really
matters say for you know our AI
overlords in the future here's the
second statement the sky is uncaught
type error i cannot read property color
of null at anonymous this is broken I
don't think you would ever want to have
this feature I mean unless maybe you
were writing like ironic JavaScript
poetry or something but like this
distinction wasn't really clear for me
until I work with functional programming
because for me this was kind of normal
life right like you can't avoid this
this is what programming is this happens
all the time it's called a bug and you
fix it and you kind of move on and the
premise of functional was yeah you can
like you can just not have these in your
wife at all and that kind of I really
really struggled with so the reason I
struggled with that is because this
definition functional will not save you
from semantics and correctness but it
can save you from things that are
actually broken we don't necessarily
need to have these in a language the
second thing that I wanted to sign out
on was this whole notion of functional
you know people say oh Java scripts
functional that's not not true but the
premise is that javascript has both
functional features and imperative
features and in between those two kind
of paradigms there are actually some
compromises yes you can draw good ideas
from both things but ultimately one of
the kind of premises of functional is
functions and the mathematical sense
where functions don't do things if a
function does something we then define
that as a procedure so straight away the
fact that you can take imperative
features and sprinkle them anywhere and
you put yourself in a situation where
there's compromises and FP practices
really require discipline so this is why
you know especially Redux is a good
example of that people who maybe are new
to the react stack and haven't used
redux before and dragged it in because
they think that
that's what they need as a baseline and
it turns out maybe they don't yet need
that now they're doing all these crazy
things all over the place and trying to
manage all this I'm kind of kind of a
boilerplate for this alleged benefit of
FP while simultaneously having the
ability to escape hatch and do their
imperative stuff and I think you know
path of least resistance the temptation
is really really hard to do imperative
features so I think my experience has
been that functional features are really
amazing loaning them helps you think
differently but ultimately we're in
you're wearing your inner code base
especially under commercial pressure or
time pressure you're going to compromise
and do the imperative things in a
functional language as I define it
you have functional features and that's
it so there is no backdoor FP practices
are the default you can't accidentally
mutate stuff you can't accidentally do
effect because it's kind of constrained
so the premise is not to infant eyes a
developer and say oh you can't manage
this stuff but actually to say hey maybe
when we don't have certain things here
it actually helps us write better code
write faster with more confidence and
that's true of what I've found you know
ok enough talking should I show you some
code ok so like I said I'm not going to
go into super detailed examples but I'm
going to give you a basic counter so
that you see a full complete could
deploy to production piece of elm code
and then I'm going to use that to talk
about the Elm architecture that's
powering things underneath does that
make sense
cool so I'm going to step through it and
I'm really sorry I hope that you can all
see is that ok for everyone or is a bit
struggling half nods ok so at the top of
a Elm file um simply open a new elm file
call it a PL or whatever you want we're
gonna put module main exposing the
syntax of dart means that we're exposing
everything in this file we could choose
to expose only certain functions if we
were writing like a little library
module but in this case we said wildcard
just include everything we're going to
import some stuff from the core library
and I'm gonna import two things from the
HTML library I'm gonna expose for
functions remember like I said before
they're all function
do anything they return values beginner
program takes a bunch of parameters and
returns a program value that elmore run
unbuttoned div and text are all
functions that take a set of arguments
for attributes a set of arguments for
children and they return a virtual
representation of what that markup might
be that's all like an init and the on
click function will take a message type
that I want to trigger and it'll give me
a tribute that I can put in an element
so in every L map you'll experience at
the basic level we write for things they
are the only four things we have a right
so once you learn these four things you
can approach any l map and immediately
know where to start and what to look for
so the four things are our initial model
which is our initial state a type we're
going to call it message you could call
it whatever you want but we're gonna
call it message this is going to be and
so if you know redux this is an action
so all the actions that our app supports
we're going to write so they're the two
they're the two models or the two two
values that we're going to write and
then we're gonna write two functions one
is an update function this update
function will receive at a given any
given point in time a message and the
current model and what we need to return
back is the new model based on our
business logic so all of the business
logic for an L map sits in this function
just one place then we've got the view
and the view is very similar to what you
might might have seen in react except
here it's explicit it explicitly takes
in a model and we will return to markup
so let's go and implement that so for
the counter we're gonna start out
counter with a value of zero our whole
model is just going to be single integer
our model could be anything it could be
a hash type with lots of things in it
which was normally what you'd get to on
it in a bigger apple let's just start
with just plain old value I'm for the
message type well we want to be able to
sort how it didn't actually show you the
the button there with sorry if you've
gone blind so this is the this is the
app that we're gonna build so you can
plus plus plus on the counter - and we
have no guards in our business logic so
you can go negative cool
okay so if you think about that up in
terms of the actions we have we really
just have two actions we want the
counter to go up we want the counter to
go down so we're going to just create to
that to type C in the message type so
message is either going to be increment
or it's going to be decrement I'm not
going to stress this too much because it
takes a little while to kind of learn
this concept but you can kind of think
of this a bit as an enumeration for now
if that makes a little bit easier or you
can note that boolean has exactly the
same type signature so type boolean is
true or false or true and false are the
actual values they get passed around you
don't really pass around the line does
that make sense so increment and
decrement are two actual values they're
kind of like labels they're labels that
we can pass around and they'll be type
checked so we can't put a label that
doesn't exist somewhere that doesn't
exist okay so our update function
usually 99 times out of 100 we will
start with a case and a case is as you
would expect the messages of the message
type so we're going to case on increment
well if we're incrementing that's the
message that we received and we're going
to return model +1 if we're decrementing
we're going to return model -1 and our
view is going to use our functions so
let's focus on this middle function
first so you can see that the divider
has no attributes so putting nothing in
the tributes just a plain div and as its
contents we're putting a text node so
that's just a root text node with no
wrapping and we're putting a two string
of our model so model is an integer to
string into the text version that's
going to be text node so that's gonna
sit in the middle before and after we're
creating two buttons the buttons do have
attributes one has an attribute of
onclick decrement the other one has an
inch a tribute of unclick increment and
then they have the individual text nodes
that they're showing and then those all
those values are wrapped in a div that
has no attributes and that's what we
returned back everyone comfortable that
they understand on a high level what
this code does syntax aside for a second
this is the last line that stitches
everything together so Elam always looks
for an entry point called Maine and in
Maine we have to give elm a program
value so it's a value that describes how
our program functions so what we're what
we're doing here is we are taking the
beginner program which is the the
function that we've got from the Encore
library and it takes a hash that has
three parameters or three attributes in
it a model a view and update so
literally the stuff that we're just
reading the four things that we've
written save for the the message type
and we say okay well this is what our
state looks like here's the initial
model take that away lovely and here's
the view function that I want you to run
for me and whenever there's a new model
and here's the update function that I
want you to run for me whenever you get
a message so the net outcome of that is
this little app and as you can see
heading plus is triggering that message
- is pulling it back down
yeah okay any questions at this point
all comfortable all right I'm just gonna
bang on the point a little bit so that
view function that we wrote takes a
model and it returns something a value
called HTML and elm it is an actual HTML
similar to the way that react does it
because Elm has a virtual Dom
implementation so it's efficiently
checking for changes and things like
that and managing the Dom for us we
don't go anywhere near the Dom we just
tell Elam well here's what I might cup
should look like for that state you gave
me so that's that's always a new set of
HTML the update model works similarly it
gets a message in the current model we
do whatever logic we want make whatever
changes we want to a new model and we
give a new model back we can't mutate
that old model so I'm gonna try
visualize it again in another way and
hopefully it just really sinks it in so
here's our own runtime which we don't
control the Elm runtime happens outside
of our control we simply gave that our
initial model we gave it our update
function we gave it a view so now we've
compiled that we've booted up our
javascript in the browser and our app is
running so we've clicked a button which
has fired one of our messages now
remember that markup can only have the
messages that we defined in our app if
we typed any other kind of message that
was unhandled that would fail at compile
time so the browser's going to give us a
message type and it's guaranteed that
that's going to be message type we know
about so the Elm runtimes immediately
going to do two things first it's going
to send that to the update function call
that update function and get back the
new model and it's going to go call I'm
gonna retain that model that's the new
model now then it's going to go write G
function here's the model get me back
that HTML great I've now got that HTML
and it's going to do the virtual Dom
diffing and calculate the Dom
differences and actually communicate
that back into the layout they're
unhappy so far with that
nods but like more furrowed brows now
hopefully furrowed because you're
thinking well this is really nice Mario
but how do you actually do anything with
the outside world so like I said before
the guarantee that we have when we're
looking at any Ellen function in code is
that it's not going to be doing effect
to say we wanted to write a little app
where you press the button and it
fetched a new gift of a hilarious cat
animation right so when that button is
pressed we would like to send an ajax
request or a request to a server to get
a new URL and we like to get that
request back and change it well actually
it functions in exactly and exactly the
same way as the browser so what we write
in terms of that app doesn't change we
still only have four things we have the
model we have the types of messages that
we can expect we have our update
function which has our business logic
and we have the view so what happens now
is when and that message type comes
through this kind of upgraded so this is
HTML dot program we were on beginner
program we've got to program now so the
type signature changes slightly update
function now returns two values instead
of one so instead of just returning the
model it now also returns an array of
what an element called commands they're
values that represent a command that Elm
may execute for you later
so you can kind of think of it like
promises that you cannot resolve there's
no mechanism in Elm to actually resolve
commands yourself the only way to
resolve it is to hand them back to the
Elm runtime so let's say we we've done
this and our request has we've asked for
Elm to do a request for our cap gif well
in the meantime one goes yeah yeah
that's nice but I'm gonna I got a new
model I'm gonna run the view and we're
going to put that stuff back in the Dom
so that whole process happens
instantaneously then at a separate
asynchronous
l may choose to take that command into
what is called an effective manager so
Elam has an implementation of a certain
set of effects that the language
supports HTTP requests are one of them
and it will execute that command now
when we issued that command what we had
to issue along with the command is an
instruction to Elm of what message type
we wanted to get back and so then Elm
deals with the busy work and the
possible failures and the Nils and all
that kind of stuff and it'll only give
us back well-defined conformed
guaranteed actually ok messages if they
happen to exist yeah so what the effect
manager will be doing is it'll be
sending back a message note that this
message and this one here the same
exactly same mechanism let's take it in
isolation so imagine that that whole
loop has happened and we've got our new
DOM and now asynchronously the effect
manager has has triggered a command for
us so there's been an event let's say
we've successfully gotten back our HTTP
request so the message that we've
defined which is a message in our update
function that accepts back the specific
value that were we're looking for will
get called for us the same thing will
happen again just exactly the same route
like as if it come from the browser we
actually don't know where it's come from
I mean it could have come from the
browser could have come from an effect
manager we only know by the semantics of
the messages the action types that we've
implemented model and HTML view gets run
again and the Dom gets output so that
same mechanism kind of works through
both versions that is the most
complicated thing that I ever had to try
and figure out what Elm so I'm really
hoping that that that unlocks a lot a
lot of the runtimes perhaps my favorite
thing about ohm is that it has the best
pair programming buddy I've ever worked
with mainly because they have no
attitude and they're never wrong and
it's just really really Pleasant you
don't have to talk to anybody like the
compiler just kind of yell stuff at you
so I'm going to give you some nice
canned scenarios first just so you see
the kind of quality of Elm error
messages okay so the first one I'll show
you
is this name okay so here we've got soon
here we've got an error from Elm and
this is how we'd come up in your console
so you could have a library loader going
and it's you save your file in it and
it's I'm spitting stuff out or I have it
directly in my editor and Ellenson said
have detect an error
it's a naming error I can't find the
variable list nap
you've loosen up a list does not expose
nap maybe you want one of the following
list of map any map to my three so it's
not a heuristic search on the name which
is really nice so it not only does it
tell you what's wrong exactly where it's
wrong give it a little indicators to
highlight specifically on which area the
line it's wrong it also gives you
suggestions rather things so this is a
live code example that I've just
reloaded and getting a little bit more
advanced than that here we've got an if
statement we've said if n is less than
zero then let's return the string
negative if n is greater than zero let's
return the string positive otherwise
let's return 42 so LM here is telling us
well you've got a type mismatch here the
second and third branches of this if
produce different types of values the
second branch of this type is a string
but the third is a number and then it
gives you these hints these these are
the best thing by far so that's the
that's the nice canned scenario which is
what normally gets talked about in talks
and so I figured it's probably better to
show you where Elm really shines in the
worst possible scenario luckily I have
the worst Elm codebase known to me which
is my own codebase and I'm just going to
go and arbitrarily change something in
the in the application that you're all
using on your phones to try and just
give you a little bit of a sense of what
it's actually like to do maths
refactorings you know so here we've got
a foreign code base that we've we've
never been in before and it's got like
tons and tons of code has no tests like
nothing like just you know like it
absolute horror someone at work
like gone full crazy on Elm that just
built all this stuff and they've quit
right now it's your job to deal with it
and you're like you're ready to like
quit your job and you know you're like
on stackoverflow looking for other stuff
anyway all right I remember Meyer has
said some stuff like I should recognize
a cell map you got up that um I'm gonna
start okay so we got a program with
Flags thing here and we kind of see like
okay in it update and subscriptions and
some stuff is here and we've kind of got
this type thing here so it seems like
types is let's say we need to extend
this app right we want to we all want to
add a new page to the presentation
software so we go okay cool well we know
that in Elm to add a new page we
probably need to find a type for that
page or we probably need to find the
actual core message type that represents
all the actions that can happen and add
something there so say we go into types
we look through we've got type page type
aliases we got things are here we go
type message we go cool so this is all
the stuff actually all of the things
that this app does there's nothing this
app does that isn't here like let that
sink in for a second it's a code base
that you've never touched before and
immediately you already know everything
that it does so let's say we go okay my
new awesome feature is the new label
like when you click a button it's going
to trigger my new awesome feature which
is going to be amazing and we save this
and what we get from what we get from
Elm basically now is a pepper everybody
that intimately knows the whole code
base and has in a split-second gone
through and checked every single file
every single include any way that this
type might be used and immediately
started coming back with errors so the
very first error that it's given us and
they're saying well your update function
which is in another part of the code
remember the update function is the main
function with all our business logic
saying that update function doesn't
cover this new feature that you have you
need to go and add that in there so we
say ok cool where's that update function
it's quite a long update function so
we're going to screw this up like I said
this is you know like
worst the worst possible code okay so it
says State DOT elm and here we go
we've found update function so let's
kind of scroll to the bottom of it it's
all the various things remember like
worst worst worst possible code my
awesome feature and let's just say we're
gonna return the model as is and we're
going to command an arm we're just not
going to do anything all right it's
going to be not out saying well can't
find pattern myosin feature why not
because it's called my new awesome
feature yes thank you pair programming
buddy I've made that change now and only
saying okay that's pretty good that's
good that is all you needed to change
nothing else in the code will break you
didn't make any other side effects
nothing else depends on that new feature
you've added you are 100% a ok to deploy
this to production so that for me is
like chalk and cheese difference to the
kind of development that I have
day-to-day so much so that I'm finding
it increasingly more difficult to
program and other languages about these
guarantees just because the level of
uncertainty that you gain by working in
a language like this kind of really
decreases your confidence in other
languages so I find myself now when I
interrupt with JavaScript in Elm and I'm
working with JavaScript stuff you know
with Elm you you you write stuff and you
compile it and it's wrong and change it
it's wrong and change it again and like
no wrong and you fix it and it's green
you're like yeah it looks like it's
pretty good and in JavaScript you change
something and you're like where's the
thing that tells me maybe it's ok I
don't know like you go to potentially
now go write tests do your tests cover
every single case potentially not so the
wrong and broken difference that kind of
broken bit just kind of disappears but
the wrong bit is still your
responsibility Iran it's somewhat
satisfied with the real life example ok
cool very quickly I'm ending off with
some high-level stuff so Alan packages
have Auto semver
so again when I talked about the nice
side effects of having enforced purity
and side-effect free code alum can look
at your library and all the type
signatures that you have exposed if you
have changed no public interfaces alum
or minor version increase if you have
added a public interface it will middle
version increase and if you have removed
a public interface it'll major version
bump your code you can't change your own
version numbers in elm packages it just
does it entirely for you the flip side
of that is when you're pulling down new
package updates Elm can automatically or
you can safely pull in minor and
intermediate versions because you know
that they haven't fundamentally they
shouldn't have changed they wouldn't
have changed any of the interfaces they
may have changed some behaviors but
generally it's a lot safer and if you're
dealing with a major change you know
that something's gonna be removed even
still bring that package in with a major
change you're pretty happy because the
Elm compile will then immediately tell
you every single place in your codebase
where your usage of that package is now
broken so you still have the protection
and optional choice on whether you want
to engage in that work or not well when
you do upgrade it gives you like a
bucket list of exactly how to upgrade
which is pretty awesome the elm packages
site if you want to kind of look at the
kind of packages that exist in the on
community and their own packages that
online to org yeah check it out that's
how much more say they're compiling Elm
so I haven't talked about how Elm
actually works in terms of compilation
so like I said even though it has all
this library stuff it is fundamentally a
separate language that has its own
runtime so it's got its own compiler so
you take you write a bunch of em Elm
files and they run through the compiler
and you get compiled JavaScript that
includes both your code and the runtime
and all the libraries and everything to
do with it all kind of packaged up if
you're in a project that has JavaScript
files already you're probably going to
want to pull in elm incrementally into
certain bits to try it out or to have
kind of some interrupts so the very very
simple way to do that is through web
pack web pack
as a Elmwood Park loader which will
simply allow you to require elm files
directly and then mount that elm app to
whatever node you actually want that to
attach to it and then run the rest of
its stuff there how do I use Elm at work
the answer is gradually there's actually
a blog post by the author of Elm himself
his name's Evan and and he talks about
the incremental approach and also what
he's seen in his experience of the the
number of years that he's been improving
Elm for Alan projects that are succeeded
and yet generally the premise is that
you take a small area of an existing app
or or if you're starting from scratch if
you have that luxury and you can just
try em out in a very small section an
experiment and see if it meets your
needs and if it works well enough for
the domain that that you write in and
then if it does you simply just take
more and more chunks of that tree or put
Elm in multiple places around your app
so for those of you that are using react
there's kind of like a canonical example
and by Avenue himself of react and
components so very simply importing Elm
wrapper fractal components you're
importing your L map from wherever might
be like the compile code and you can
just put that straight into a react
render function there's a very simple
example there's more complicated example
so if you want to pass some values of an
alum initially or if you want to
actually talk to and from their own
application but all of this is like a 20
line wrapper it's really really simple
so just with plain JavaScript you
literally brick if you're using the ELMO
pack later you're requiring that
javascript that you've written and you
can just embed it to a node that's the
only attach point to get started cool
Cabot's general-purpose programming
language it gets kind of thrown around a
lot and so something that I again I got
cut on so I kind of want to put out
there Elm doesn't run on the server side
yet it's not a server-side language and
it's not a general-purpose language you
could run it on the server if you really
wanted to
I mean 0.19 the next version there may
be some server-side rendering stuff
because a lot of people have been asking
about that but there is a really really
good document about general-purpose
language written again written by oven
that I would recommend reading if that
kind of infuriates you for some reason
because actually really clear and
articulate on why this kind of premise
doesn't really exist so you know we
might say Python is a general-purpose
programming language but you're not
going to go write assembly in it and
might say see is a general-purpose
programming language but you're not
going to do web development in it so
general-purpose languages do still have
specializations so Alamos is saying that
since its specialization really is to be
really awesome at front-end apps
fiddling with the Dom you're going to
have a bad time if you really really
convinced that you really really need a
fiddle with the Dom or you have some
application that that's for some reason
doing something with external libraries
and pulling in markup and and all that
kind of stuff and that is not something
that Elm allows or is any good at really
and you can still achieve what you
wanted if you talk the reports to some
JavaScript kind of interrupt but on that
side as well javascript interrupt is
really really strict in order for Elm to
preserve those kind of guarantees of
runtime safety and not exploding on you
I'm the way that it talks in and out of
JavaScript is also through a really
strict typed interface so make sure that
the types that come back are actual
types that your app can handle and keeps
anything else out I'm so kind of all the
JavaScript errors stay on the outside
and the arm stuff stays pure and yeah
this one's a little bit cynical but you
you little II may be more frustrated
with other languages at least I have
been cool thoughts after two years of
functional programming it's not a silver
bullet I'm not claiming that this is the
solution for all problems like I said
before I'm not suggesting we go to Linus
Torvalds and say hey let's rewrite Linux
and Elm but I think if you're doing web
development and you're writing web apps
which is specifically what Elm is
engineered for I think it trades off for
better problems
um the constraints that it gives you
it's kind of like Lego if you've played
with Lego as a kid you probably didn't
think man I really wish I could just put
glue and and wood sticks and cut the
LEGO pieces in half right are you just
going to go are they snap together and
suddenly you can you build all these
kind of things so for me FP is that same
kind of thing I don't see the typesafe -
I've never felt
to be a restriction it's just been kind
of like an enabler but if you really
really need glue and sticks will then
use glue and sticks I'm yet to see a
broken runtime I haven't seen one yet
there are various edge cases that can
cause them you can look them up on the
online tracker
I think they've gotten them down to like
four or three now
um reveals your mistakes so as part of a
previous talk I talked about why l made
me realize how terrible of a programmer
I am it's actually a positive because it
improves your code overall but it kind
of does show you like I said before that
lowers that confidence that you have in
other languages because it increases
your visibility of just how much you're
not seeing that you're not catching and
refactoring is really awesome I before
the last presentation and that I did
this live talk with I decided to change
something from a single field to like an
array like I had a 1 of something and I
wanted to have a multi of something and
I changed it and it broke the whole code
base because my whole thing had been
built with a previous premise of a
singular relationship and 15 minutes
before the presentation I was like yeah
why not manage to get like all the stuff
checked off and all changed and
compiling and deployed it and went
flawlessly so my experience with that
has been that at a baseline level in the
worst possible scenario writing the most
terrible code with no tests you still
end up in my experience better off than
other languages that don't have these
guarantees and you do have those kind of
tests ok
further reading watching the Elm guide
is kind of like the canonical intro
it'll teach you all the stuff that I've
violently skipped over like actual
syntax and the type for sevales are
available and some of the library
functions a lot of this talk I've kind
of ripped bits and pieces out from Kevin
yank who does a much better and more
eloquent job with much nicer slides and
so check out developer happiness on the
front end with Elm especially if you
also work with rails you may find that
interesting
and then to talks recently that I think
really address two problems that that
kind of people run into when they come
to them because it's such a different
paradigm is you your app gets larger and
larger and you want to scale it or you
you
start with a foul and like me I kind of
started my first file and once it got to
a hundred lines or like oh this is bad
ten files in like modular structure and
all this kind of stuff in and so Evan
talks about why that's the the reasons
that we do that in other languages
aren't actually present in elm that
doesn't make sense to do that so he
talks through a really beautiful example
of those kind of assumptions and how
they fall over in the life of the file
and growing kind of modules out and then
Richard Feldman talks about scaling all
naps until much larger extent Richard
works at a company called no red ink and
I think it's two hundred thousand lines
at UM code and production they have and
their claim is that they still haven't
had a single runtime exception so I
think that's that's pretty cool so if
you want to see either of those kind of
things take it from the horse's mouth
fair that's all I've got
thank you
[Applause]